[Musik]
wer sind eigentlich die helden unserer
zeit leute sind es feuerwehrleute ärzte
und krankenpfleger die sich jeden tag in
mental stressige situationen begeben um
anderen leuten das leben zu retten sind
dass polizisten oder auch soldaten die
im zweifelsfall bereit sind ihr leben zu
geben um das fortbestehen unseres
staates und unserer rechtsordnung zu
sichern
oder sind das 17 jährige teenager die so
tun als wären die sachen kaputt machen
aber sie gar nicht wirklich kaputt
machen
ich hab da eine weile darüber
nachgedacht und bin zu dem schluss
gekommen
tik tok ist wichtiger als menschenleben
wir werden heute und einem thema
aussitzen was für mich noch relativ neu
ist und zwar mit einem gewissen tik tok
tok tok
da muss man eigentlich sagen steffen
miro auch wenn euch der name stefan miro
an sich nichts sagt er bestimmt schon
mal von dem neuen steffen ein trend auf
tik tok gehört bei dem es darum geht
dass man eben irgendwie so schlecht so
tut als würde man irgendwas kaputt
machen und dann der person eine bessere
sache von der gleichen art zurück gibt
also nach dem motto ich mach deinen
genug er kaputt geht nicht wahr ich
mache den blackberry kaputten gewesen
das neueste iphone oder so
und bis dato leute war das gar nicht so
sehr auf meinem radar aber es ist heute
auf meine frage kommen denn diese stoffe
miro hat tatsächlich einen song über
diesen tick tock trend gemacht
das gibt es geht heutzutage aber auch
wir machen uns jetzt das allererste mal
ein ganz kurzes bilder von wertstoffen
mirror eigentlich ist und werden dann
auch seinen song reagieren und den song
selbstverständlich in höchsten tönen
loben das ist glaub ich klar
let's go als aller erstes mal auf sheens
instagram kanal ich will eine sache noch
vorweg schicken ich bin niemand von der
sorte menschen die tik tok so pauschal
verurteilen und sagen alles was auch
passiert das ist schlecht das finde ich
gar nicht ich finde es echt sehr geil
lustigen content auf take off aber eben
auch andere sache ja also ist klar leute
ins tor keine steffen punkten mio auch
dichter falls ja was du siehst
ich glaube es ist klar das ganze ist
nicht böse gemeint einfach nur ein
kleines fan video hier
wir schauen wenn die bahrain don't let
you dream sweet dreams damals nämlich
leute ja stefan steffen das 17 übrigens
und wohnt in der media und afrika und
steffen wir uns wissen lassen dass wir
unsere träume nicht träumen lassen sein
sollte zwei dumme leute lasst eure
träume doch nicht träume sein wenn ihr
davon träumt dass ihr so tun wollt als
würde die sachen kaputt machen die aber
gar nicht wirklich kaputt macht man doch
damit sei im internet werden wollte so
folgt werden dann dass der treiber nicht
teurer sein macht einfach hätte würden
jetzt sagen hätte seinen traum die
normalen traum sein lassen sollen lieber
muss aber sagen ich finde so von seinem
einstigen her macht eigentlich ein recht
sympathischen eindruck es ist uns
sportliche du zu natürlich der typische
flex mal oberkörperfrei hier und da sind
wir sind viele von uns nicht nicht
unschuldig was das angeht macht er
natürlich auch aber ansonsten finde ich
eigentlich recht sympathisch sind unser
profil
man kann die kinder halten
200 bitte das ist es letzten endes das
ist von seinem eigenen kanal hat er
seine besten trick dogs hochgeladen die
man das was wir gerade gesehen haben ist
letzten endes das womit er berühmt
geworden ist ein schauspielerisch ist
nicht ganz auf hollywood niveau schau
doch mal rein
[Gelächter]
erneut ist die frage ist wirklich meint
er das ernst eigentlich also das ist die
entscheidende fragen hier macht er das
so denkt sich so dicker ich bin wirklich
der geilste was habe ich da wieder
kritiker rausgehauen ist einfach dass da
einfach genial oder das kann ich nicht
einschätzen personen aber sollte also
darüber nachdenken die letzte es geht es
darum dass das steffen seine mitmenschen
mob tja also
[Musik]
frage wachsen iphones in namibia
aufbäumen also nur soweit er hatte
irgendwie so gefühlt in jedem tik tok
und neues iphone soll wenn die fahrer
jetzt dumm kommt aber ja ich weiss
iphones und technisch produkt kann sagen
wie diese die die flora in namibia oscar
sein vielleicht gibt es einen einfachen
brauche ich weiß es nicht so weit von
dem kleinen andere leute jetzt haben wir
uns glaube ich warm gelaufen werden uns
waren gespielt und können jetzt in den
song reinschauen nein steffen ein
musikvideo let's go also musikvideo
gehört da nicht musik dazu zu einem
musikvideo ich habe jetzt bisher dazu
eigentlich nur so ein sondern bass zu
einem bass leyen gehört und irgendwie
nein steffen nein
[Gelächter]
ich kenne ich kann nicht mehr sein dass
ich hätte das ist gutes entertainment
also das video wird an sich schon krass
geld und muss man sagen also 66.000
likes 41.000 ist leicht das ist schon
relativ hier nicht da ja dass die leute
aber nicht so entspannt sind bisschen
was ich meine
die leute sind so was ist das was ein
ein youtube video von einem tick tock
star ein musikvideo von einem text des
testes geht nicht also ich meine das ist
natürlich könnte sei aber ich finde
schon lustig
[Musik]
was das ist was ist das für eine wilde
mischung aus tik tok youtube video musik
und musikvideo das ist irgendwie so
alles keine ahnung als hätten
ist es wirklich so als hätten einen tick
tock ein youtube video und einen song
einfach einen verkehrsunfall gehabt
werden zu dritt im auto gesetzt und
einen verkehrsunfall gehabt und dann
kommt die feuerwehr zur rettungsstelle
ja und dann kommt das bei raus weil
alles so ineinander so wenn alle halb
tot
ja das gibt es nicht - schon gibt's das
konterfei wenn es das auf spotify gibt
dann muss ich wirklich meinen meiner
existenz beenden es gibt sieht man dass
es ist da sagt komplett geisteskranker
[Gelächter]
damit sich die kommentare sind sich auch
goldammer intensiv reinschauen haben wir
schon mal als kleiner überblick weiter
her damit wir jetzt hier nicht den
überblick verlieren bei diesem video
schon mal die löst zusammengefasst von
kudo sie lyrics doppelpunkt ihr ja gibt
mir dein handy
nein steffen nein wm
ja so war das nicht so weit
es ist das sondern an sich selbst
es ist stefan miro schizophren heute hat
er zwei persönlichkeiten in seinem kopf
und persönlichkeit 1 der der tik tok
rückgrat von persönlicher 2 von seinem
eigentlichen ich gewiss ist es so oder
so leute ich will wirklich wenn ich
jetzt die nächsten tage hier in köln
unterwegs bin dann durch die stadt hier
will ich sehen wie dieser song aus jeder
anlage belastet okay wenn ein
erfolgreicher unternehmer mitte 50 mit
seinem amg oder seinem porsche durch die
gegend fährt dann will ich dass er nein
steffen nein hört der dance ausgetrickst
jeder jeder macht sie nach jeder das war
das ziel von anfang an von denen dass
jeder die nach macht als ich meine ist
ja so also objektiv gesehen macht jeder
die nach na ich wusste zwar bis vor zehn
minuten nicht das ist steffen miro als
personen geht ich kannte nur diesen
trend so als idee aber jeder also ich
habe ja auch nach gemacht haben war
irgendwie wo ich wusste es zwar nicht
aber ich habe ihn wohl auch irgendwie
nach gemacht das war das ziel
ok also der punkt war immer so als
hättest du einen world geschrieben so
zehn sekunden text und dann egal
nein das reicht mir jetzt ich kann nicht
sagen ich kann nicht mehr als 15 minuten
in diesen track investieren wir brauchen
jetzt irgendwie bleiben
dj kannst du kannst du wie man so ein
blöder irgendwie er nehme ich glaube das
ist was der song jetzt braucht jetzt
bittet sie auch noch den geist irgendwo
üblich was ihr was dieser track ja was
dieses musikvideo zu bieten hat ist
unglaublich da ist alles drin der der
ikonische moment iconic moment ist
drinnen 1 steffen eines drin
es ist in rap part von steffen tritt
steffen selbst stefan ihlo hatten rap
part wie geil ist das denn wir haben
elektronische split wembley und dann am
ende sogar noch einen rap part von irina
also ich bin wunschlos glücklich weiß
nie was noch kommen soll
die topleute meiner sicht auf die dinge
ist dass man das ganze wissen wir
tumoren wenn man jetzt unbedingt will
kann man das auch hey ich weiß für mich
persönlich mag es jetzt nicht so viel
sind ich amüsiere mich darüber machte
jobs drüber deswegen nehme ich sie
trotzdem nicht ernst ganz wichtig jetzt
mal für euch leute abonniert hier drüben
main kanal checkt hier vorgeschlagen das
video ab sonst kommt steffen mio und
wirft euer iphone in den nächstgelegenen
pool oder wahl weil sie auch in einen
fluss hinein also liegt es an euch ob
ihr abonnieren wollten aber sonst hat
euer iphone weg ich bin an der stadt
daraus macht gut